you're making everything about a Visa
I'm making everything about a life your
mind is like yeah like this yeah you
can't see like this
but see you didn't talk about the
marriage we talk about the plan why you
mix these things with these things
because the most important thing and the
most sacred thing is marriage and love
that's the first thing that's the
foundation
love can conquer anything but you don't
have enough strong love for me to
accomplish a life here so you never had
unconditional love for me and I'm glad
to know that now
you'll never believe in my love
I did Believe in Your Love what do you
think made me come all the way to
Morocco and move because of your love I
believed in you I love it you but you
didn't accept this
your love is conditional
I can only love Debbie if she takes me
to the United States
[Music]
that's what you're saying
I'm not used to this loss of stress when
you fight or something like this She
always told me that you don't love me
you don't care about me and that kind of
stuff
love for me is something holy not when
probably happens I run away
so this is affects my my heart it's true
day after day after day it makes me love
her less
[Music]
we've changed
because I know you deeply I noticed the
change well I think Debbie's getting
stronger and you don't like Debbie to be
stronger no and you can guarantee the
future here is dying here so how you
want to live in a vocal no I'm staying
here you will lose your money I've got
money my money is my business and I was
willing to build the foundation for us I
know my country
you don't know squat man you don't know
squat
talk to the hand because
I've heard so much BS coming from you
so
I'm going to go on without you
and I'm going to forge A New Path
but you wimped out on me
[Music]